for some days now the hashtag released
the Snider cut has been around on
Twitter we are talking about the Zack
Snyder card of Justice League which is
now demanded by several prominent
Hollywood celebrities among them are Ben
Affleck Wonder Woman gal gadot and Ray
Fisher who portrays the cyborg and
Justice League
Snyder's response on Twitter was also
immediate as he shared the tweets and
added a comment that both Batman and
Wonder Woman can't be wrong the timing
of the tweets is also no coincidence as
it falls exactly on the day when Justice
League was released two years ago
however many fans and actors are still
not satisfied with the work published at
that time and demand to version by Zack
Snyder who could not finish the film for
personal reasons so he was not
responsible for the final version but
what are the chances that we will see
the Snyder version in the foreseeable
future
probably rather poor because the studio
responsible Warner Brothers would have
to invest a lot of money marketing
special effects and potential
re-releases to get the Snyder version on
the market especially since justice
league itself was very expensive and
didn't make enough money also the
magazine Hollywood Reporter claims to
know that one is definitely not planning
a release at the moment would you like
to see the Snyder cut then according to
some industry magazines you should join
the release the Snyder cut movement as
well after all today's film studios look
very closely at what their fans are
demanding online as we've recently seen
at Sonic a director has finally been
found who will take over the sequel of
the couch Eddy's movie Robocop little
monsters director aid for science is
said to have been hired to direct the
script of the original authors Edward
Neumeier and Michael minor which was
created together with terminator dark
fate author Jason Rhodes similar to
Halloween or the new edition of
Terminator the unpopular sequels Robocop
2 & 3 will be ignored which means that
the new Robocop will directly tie in
with the original of 1987 whether the
Robocop franchise can also be modernized
however is questionable
a similar attempt was already made in
2014 with a new robot
which however fell far short of
expectations director Forsyth cream ice
will probably be similar to the one of
its predecessor namely Tuesday as close
as possible to the brutal and satirical
original when we will see policeman alex
murphy in his robot body on screen again
isn't certain yet however in december
2022 the first Star Wars movie by the
game of thrones makers David Byrne IO
and DB Weiss was supposed to be released
in the cinemas as we reported they left
the Star Wars universe a few weeks ago
due to other commitments the day 2022
for a new film still exists for
Lucasfilm however according to a rolling
stone interview with Kathleen Kennedy it
is not yet clear what the next film
after episode 9 will look like according
to many journalists this is exactly the
point because Kennedy is an experienced
and competent producer but not a
creative mastermind like for example
Kevin Feige from Marvel he is not only a
great expert on comic books but also
approvals the cast of the film's
Kennedy's disadvantage in the creative
field could now be compensated by
someone completely different namely
Mandalorian producer Jon Favreau who
according to The Hollywood Reporter will
have a lot to say about Star Wars in the
future many fans would probably wish
that referer would take up a position
similar to that of Kevin Feige in any
case he has already gained a lot of
experience among others as director of
Iron Man or The Lion King remake but his
greatest merit for the Star Wars
franchise is certainly the Mandalorian
series which has been running on this
necklace since the beginning of November
and has been well received by fans and
critics it remains to be seen whether he
will eventually take over Kathleen
Kennedy's position on Star Wars before
that he is still busy with jungle book 2
and the second season of the mandalorian
at first it was said that there
shouldn't be a sequel to The Joker movie
now it seems that the tide has turned
because as The Hollywood Reporter
reports despite some statements there
will probably be a joke or two according
to the magazine director Todd Phillips
is currently in negotiations for a
sequel to the best r-rated movie of all
time
his scriptwriter scott silver who is
said to have made a significant
contribution to the
focus portrayal will also return next to
Philips the big question of course is
whether leading actor Joaquin Phoenix
will also be seen as the clown in front
of the camera again The Hollywood
Reporter also think to have an answer to
this question as Phoenix contract should
contain a clause similar to other
franchise films that can get him back
for possible sequels and this even
though Todd Phillips actually stated
from the beginning that Joker was
supposed to be a one-time thing for
which no sequel is planned but at that
time nobody had expected that the Joker
which was produced relatively cheaply
for a film of its size with
approximately 63 million u.s. dollars
could break the magic 1 billion dollar
mark
however the sequel is definitely not yet
set because as Phillips pointed out in
the past days certain conditions are
attached to a sequel among other things
he has to come up with something really
worth telling about the protagonist
Arthur Flagg and that he could under
certain circumstances includes a sad
story about Batman and Cove we are
curious if Phillips will come to an
agreement with one and of course we will
keep you up to date on further Joker
news
[Music]